oh
good evening members welcome to this
evening's meeting of North West area
planning committee I'm just going to
find my way back to my prompt for a
moment
my name's councilor Maddie Thompson I'm
the chairman of this committee members
please note we're streaming the meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you're giving
your consent to being recorded during
each item please put your hand up to
indicate if you wish to speak and I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of microphones therefore can
I ask when invited to speak you remember
to turn on your microphone and turn it
off when finished please reference a
page or paragraph number when referring
to the agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible
right item two is the apologies for
absence so may I please have the
apologies Miss Casey
[Music]
thank you very much thank you very much
right item three is the minutes it's
recommended that the meetings the
minutes of the meeting held on the 10th
of August and found on pages whatever it
is because I'm afraid I've ended up
without a Chairman's prompt
um
be approved as a true and accurate
record members can I take those as read
right I I so
proposed do I have a seconder yeah
and are there any matters of accuracy
coming coming from that
I'll take that as a no okay so can we
agree pause please Paul agreed thank you
okay item four is Declaration of
interest to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other registerable interests
and non-register registrable interests
relating to turn items of business on
the agenda having regard to paragraph 9
and appendix B of the code of conduct
for members and members are reminded
they're also required to disclose any
such interest as soon as they become
aware should the knees arise through the
meeting
members
councilor Durham
yeah thank you chairman um so I have an
other registerable interest as a member
of Essex County Council I think I've got
that one right I think it's probably an
other registerable interest because
um the applicant is known to me in his
capacity because he is a member of
wooden Mortimer Parish Council so
um and and he's in of a farming family
and I very much doubt that there's
anybody here that doesn't know one
member of the family around the county
but um I I'm not on social terms uh with
the uh with the applicant
as I said I'm sure everybody knows one
of them it's another big Essex farming
family
thank you generally I'm just reiterating
what councilor Durham said I also know
the all of certainly the family of the
applicants um of these applicants family
in terms of their his attendance on the
wooden mortal kits okay thank you
Council please
yeah fairly similar um coming from a
family Fame and a Polish company that I
used to be involved in we've probably
done all this for them but many years
ago now so it's a non-burguniary
interest okay thank you I appreciate how
complicated this is because the code of
conduct is so new to the best of my
knowledge it hasn't been tested anywhere
it hasn't been challenged anywhere and
we don't really know quite where we are
so everyone's declaring everything which
is
which is okay so we move on to a gender
item five which is
Hall Farm Malden Road wooden Mortimer
we do have a speaker
um and could we have the presentation
first please
thank you chairman
the application seeks planning
permission for the construction of a
detached Annex at Hall farm this
application follows a previously refused
application for an Annex at the site
under application reference 22
40074 forward slash ful
the previous application was refused in
April of this year under delegated
authority as the applicant had failed to
demonstrate that the proposal would fall
within the annex criteria detailed
within the specialist housing need
supplementary planning document
The Proposal was also considered to
result in the spread and intensification
of the domestic use of the site to the
detriment of the character and
appearance of the countryside the
current application has not made any
amendments to the proposed location or
design of the building but has provided
additional information as part of the
design and access statement in an in an
attempt to overcome the previous reason
for refusal
this is the site location plan for the
application the site is located on the
Northern side of Malden Road and is
located outside of the defined
settlement of wooden Mortimer within the
countryside
this is the proposed block plan for the
application showing that the proposed
Annex would be situated on an area of
land to the northwest of the main
dwelling which is here
for the reasons discussed at section 5.1
of the committee report this area of
land is not considered to be part of the
lawful cartilage of the main dwelling
yeah
this is the site plan which shows the
location of the proposed building in
relation to the main dwelling as you can
see from the line here shown on the
western boundary of the main Garden
um
the area of land which the building
would be located is separated by a
boundary brick wall trees and hedgerows
although access to this area of land can
be taken via a small Gap in the wall
here
um the out building is located over 40
meters from the main house as the crow
flies
there is also the potential for the site
to be accessed from the north
here
leading around here to the adjacent
commercial site and for the reasons as
discussed within section 5.1 of the
report these site circumstances would
mean that the building would not have a
clear connection with the main dwelling
and it would be difficult to prevent the
proposal from becoming a separate
residential unit in the future
these are the proposed elevations of the
building
and this is the proposed floor plan
um discussed at paragraph
5.1.9 of the report the applicants have
advice that the proposed building would
be used as a office and a home gym by
the younger members of the family
but no further details have been
provided about the potential occupiers
of the building as they have advised
that the building is not proposed to use
for specialist housing accommodation at
this time
there's no functional link with the main
dwelling has been demonstrated The
Proposal would not therefore be
considered as an Annex
these are photographs of the access
Drive located at the rear of the site
where the proposed development can be
accessed from
this is a photograph showing the piece
of land in which the building would be
situated and the dividing wall between
the main Garden area here
and the proposed Annex over here
this is another photo show in the
location
[Music]
um as well as the access to the site
from the north
and this these are photographs just
showing the site in relation to the
neighboring commercial yard and the
access as already described here
in line with the assessment carried out
within the committee report it is the
officer's position that the applicant
has failed to demonstrate that the
proposed building would form ancillary
Annex accommodation and has not met the
criteria for Annex accommodation uh set
out with within the supplementary
planning guidance concerns are raised
with respect to the distance of the
building away from the main dwelling the
potential for the site to be subdivided
in the future without a degree of
dependency on the main dwelling and the
lack of identification of dependent
relatives that would occupy the building
the additional information submitted has
not overcome the previous reason for
refusal and the application is therefore
recommended for a refusal thank you
chairman thank you we have a public
speaker that's
Kate Jennings the agent I'm sure you
know the drill
please make yourself comfortable please
use the microphone and you have
precisely two minutes from when you
start to speak thank you madam chairman
I'd just like to cover a couple of
points off for clarity the Garden area
was established prior to 2005 as is
evident on aerial imagery and has been
regularly used as part of the garden
ever since the access between the two
areas of the garden has been in situ for
over 17 years and it's not uncommon for
Gardens to be
compartmentalized or subdivided and
that's the case in this instance which I
don't think the photos do justice too
the applicant would also like to correct
that there is no direct access to this
site from the north unless you take a
long walk along the farm track across
the fields and down through between the
ponds access is proposed through the
garden gate next to the house across the
garden patio and into the across into
the lawn
uh the council admits in their in the
officer's report their Direction with
these applications is to refuse where
they consider the proposals go beyond
what would be reasonably what would
reasonably satisfy the functional needs
of the occupant
the applicant has identified the link
will be ancillary and functional the
applicant has two young adults living at
home but in addition the family has four
elderly parents who are likely to become
dependents at some stage in the future
the proposed Annex is linked to the
family units are not proposed to be used
by anyone other than family who will be
dependent on the applicants who reside
in the house
there is a clear functional ancillary
element to the sighting of this proposal
we do not consider it unreasonable
just in reference to the high court case
cited by the officer in her report the
adults wouldn't Secretary of State case
can concurred that separation of the
unit is a matter of fact and degree
in fact in that case the inspector
concluded that the accommodation whilst
a self-contained unit was intended to
function as an Annex with the occupier
sharing her living activity in company
with the family of the main dwelling
based on this connection with the main
dwelling there's no reason in law why
such accommodation should consequently
become a separate planning unit from the
main dwelling in the future it's
therefore not a given that every Annex
will become a separate planning unit and
subdivided from the main house and it's
an unreasonable assumption to make in
this instance understandably policy set
out criteria reply in most cases but
judging this as a matter of fact and
degrees so I don't think it applies
sorry I'm afraid
thank you very much same rules for
everyone thank you
ah right members if you'd like to ask
any questions begin a discussion and
hopefully out of that proposal will
follow councilor Dara Marshall yeah
thank you I I I did call this in and I
apologize to members that I've dragged
them in for just a single item on the
agenda but one of the reasons was that
both this application and previous ones
have been supported by the parish
council obviously with the applicant
um In Absentia
um I
I just take issue with a couple of
points um about the second access to the
north unless the lady has just said you
know it's not just out onto a road it's
you've got a trek across Fields And if
you look on Google Earth as I'm doing at
the moment
um it isn't not easily accessible and
certainly not separable from from the
farm
this is very clearly again and I'm
looking at the um Google Earth it's very
clearly within the residential cartilage
in appearance and I understand that
there is some discrepancy with with
whether that is it's technical
um
standing
um
but it is very clearly part of the part
of the garden and this particular
building is tucked behind an office
block and sort of storage rooms as far
as I can see it's a single story
building
um which is not very attractive so in
terms of visual impact there is
absolutely none at all because you
there's
large buildings in front of it I think
it you know it in my humble opinion it's
clearly
um ancillary too uh to the dwelling
house
um and you know we we should take it on
face value that that is what it's being
applied for
um and we can't really
we can't really take into account what
might happen in the future because you
know we're often told that you know that
would be dealt with under a separate
planning application I just think that
you know
um this is a well-established
large multi-generational and and
Essex farming family
um and no doubt there are um aged
members I mean in the due course it may
well be required for them to to use it I
I I'm not aware of any immediately
but I just think that on balance and it
is on balance and I take it take on
board what the officer says but I'm
looking at 5.1.1
um where which refers to the ldp it says
however
um
small unobtrusive extensions of
residential cartilage into the
countryside which will not adversely
affect the character of the site and The
Wider Countryside may be approved
ensuring that provision is made to
suitable Landscaping to ensure boundary
treatments of an appropriate rural
character and appearance and in my
opinion this ticks all of those
particular boxes
um I accept the fact that there are
um that there are some of the
definitions for specialist needs housing
that haven't been ticked but then there
are some that are ticked so I'm happy to
keep an open mind on this but that is
the reason chairman that I brought it
forward to this committee
thank you
um I've got councilor Keys then
councilman Morgan
now being a farmer of this trapeze he
could put an agricultural Barn up there
and wouldn't even have to go for a
planning permission which would look as
we look at the photo not that one if we
could go back a couple of photos
asbestos or concrete asbestos roof or
metal colliding whatever they use now
there we are on the right hand side of
the picture and jump through all the
Hoops to get that he could even put some
duck up there due to the ponds and all
the reservoirs what they are we're even
having to go through playing permission
but it's agriculture so you know this
from the signs of what I can see here
looks a nice it's certainly not an
eyesore I think Council Dam stole a bit
of my thumb out you'll never be able to
see it from the road as we all know you
know the house and that as you drive
down the road it's all been over the
years it's been Diversified into little
units at the front of the place and yes
I yeah I I personally can't see a
problem with it either in the access we
all over the access it's nice access So
yeah thank you thank you I mean to be
fair you could have a barn but you
wouldn't be able to live in it
um councilman
oh yes thank you madam chairman um in
terms of the uh can I just clarify the
situation with regards to an Annex is
its distance from the the uh the house
that's going to be an artillery
is is that simply as I say a question of
fact and degree there's no specific
distance that's required so ultimately
it's a it's a sort of professional or a
judgment based on
right thank you for that um I mean I'm
just really picking up on councilor
Durham's points I mean I'm I'm not clear
I'm not clear frankly if the report has
actually convinced me that this site is
not within the residential curtainage
it's Moon I mean the the fact that
there's a wall there I don't think is
relevant particularly if there's uh
other you know obviously there's an
access there many many people have
walled areas within within their Gardens
and I think also significant is the um
is the pond there which I think is
obviously designed to be part of the
sort of a feature of immunity of the of
the Garden area to the house so I I I'm
not convinced that in terms of fact and
degree that being where it is is going
to be
um outside of what would could be
required as an ancillary Annex going on
from that however is there a possibility
that one could
make some form of condition that any
such uh dwelling there is is going to
going to be used by the family uh that's
actually resistant at that time I mean I
know you could put a covenant on there
legally but I'm just thinking from a
planning point of view whether there's
any such
um
yeah
um all right thank you chairman
um
no I do agree some of the matters are
fact and degree yeah that comes through
through appeal decisions we do
understand that
um we take the application is totality
and we take the totality of that in
terms of the
um
the policies and the and the guidance
that we apply
um yeah not everything can necessarily
have all the same weight in so I do
appreciate that yeah
um the fundamental position here is that
um
meeting the criterias within the SPD and
one of the fundamental criterias for it
being analyx
and therefore in a way uh that type of
residential accommodation being granted
as an exception yeah would be to meet
the functional need test
that has clearly not been demonstrated
and we have Annex applications all the
time yeah I even sometimes get mixed up
which while I'm dealing with because
they you know we get so many of them
understandably in a in a district of
this nature uh with a sort of kind of
land lands we're dealing with we are
quite strict on the uh criteria
um in the vast majority of those cases
um the functional need is demonstrated
you have designated persons yeah
um in need of a particular sort uh uh
support but at the same time want to
maintain a certain level of Independence
yeah that's normally always demonstrated
we we do not support where
um and this has been backed up by a
recent appeal decision which is also set
out or indicated in the
officers report
um
and I do have it here so I can speak to
a Verbatim if needed
um where you know the association is
very yeah there may be
elderly persons somewhere
in the site of an age
male may not we don't know yeah in the
cases that we're used to dealing where
they are there they've identified their
needs are identified in many a case it
may even be backed up by medical
evidence that sort of thing yeah
um
and yeah that carries a lot of weight
there is no such evidence in this
application of that nature in fact it's
very big he said sometime in the future
who knows what we can't
in an application like this we can't
just make a decision on that sometime in
the future which may or may not happen
when it comes to making an exception
um in terms of our policies it has to be
quite specific in this case this has not
been met this is the second application
um this second application has not
submitted any substantive information
um apart from a uh planning permission
reference going back to 2011
regarding a two-story extension there
was an opportunity through the reasons
for refusal to address the points of the
first reasons for refusal that has not
been done
thank you chairman thank you I have got
your counselor
um councilor Morley hasn't spoken yet
he's ahead of you thank you
um councilor Morgan brought out it was
my question was about the distance
between the buildings you know what is
there a definite measurement
and and how do you
how do you determine if that's in the
cartilage or not you know it's very
difficult when it is when it does look
like that is is there a way that you you
came or come to that decision
yeah
thank you chairman
um there is I mean there's no there's no
distance
defined to say this is what it is yeah
it's it is based on fact and degree but
I mean for example we get applications
where somebody would Redline
a field as being there you know
cartilage I mean that's clearly not the
case cartilage in planning terms does
tend to mean a a definable area
surrounding uh the the the the the the
the the dwelling which is relatively
contained you know I mean given the fact
that you know we do have some large
Gardens but they're not normally field
sized yeah yeah
um and in in in planning terms that that
kind of fact and degree assessment is
what is recognizable yeah
um and it's relative to objective to the
size of the plot the size of the house
so that sort of thing that's the degree
that that remake yeah
um if
um the thing about planning decisions
that we make
um obviously people look at these things
they they see well what precedent has
been set by permissions made by the
planning Authority okay they've allowed
the cursor list to be a field yeah so
what's the argument against
me coming along presenting my argument
I've got a field you know the the I want
to propose something
you know several hundred meters away
because that's the size of the plot yeah
sort of where do you stop how do you do
you define this is the professional
judgment that we have to apply on a
case-by-case basis so so there so there
is no fixed thing I mean the same sort
of quite I mean obviously if you've got
a residential dwelling in a built up
area it's easy to define the cartilage
yeah but when we're talking about large
tracts of land this is where we have to
start making the distinctions
um these are these are sites which are
adjacent to large fuels maybe Woods
um commercial areas these are sort of
things all these are matters that we
sort of take into considerations and
when officers come to these decisions
and and and and make a decision which
includes that element of consideration
those are the factors we take into
consideration come on thank you chairman
yeah it's just yeah that's fine but just
in in these particular cases in
particular farming they are
quite family orientated it's not like
any other business and they do I mean my
father's 88 and he's still farming yeah
it does they do go on and on luckily
I'm just saying
[Music]
my point is you have to look at this
so yeah I I take what you mean if it was
just a big country house
but you can see it's you know Farm
business and
and a family that have gone on for a
long time
it kind of
I think takes a slightly different slant
to it in my view
yes of course that was done through
YouTube
Channel
um also when we're looking at the
cartilage in this instance it's not just
a physical layout that we were looking
at which you do tend to look at Garden
boundaries boundary treatments
cartilage being an area close to the
house but we also look at the historic
use of the land so
um I can get the block plan up if it's
easier
the
this area here
is what you'd expect is the ordinary
residential Garden land in association
with the dwelling house whether or not
that whole area in itself is cartilage
because cartilage is different to
gardenland but in terms of looking at
the historic use as well as the physical
layout this piece of land was not used
as residential Garden land until
it I think the agent said 2005 it
started to be moan and rugby posts were
put on it from 2005 onwards but it
really started to be incorporated into
this Garden in 2011 onwards so we don't
just look at the physical layout which
in itself is separate from the main
Garden we look at its historic use and
it's such a recent use which hasn't
actually benefited from planning
permission
um so
to call it cartilage just because it's
been used as Garden land within the last
10 years
doesn't constitute that it's cartilage
so that's those are the factors that we
looked at in this case
um and also just to I think councilor
Keys you mentioned about an agricultural
building being put on the land
if that was the case as permitted
development then that demonstrates that
this piece of land is not residential
cartilage
um and it was in associate used in
association with the original Farm until
this Hedgerow was planted which I
believe was in 2011 but I can check my
report but those are the factors we look
at thank you
right I continue reaching to come back
councilor Durham but I have got
councilor white
thank you uh Council white and I have
got you Council yeah thank you madam
chairman um I I just got the farm up
here on
um Google Earth
and um what I'm what I'm interested in
is that I'm looking at the location and
for me that's definitely Garden land
when you look at the rest of it it's
either industrial units or it's farm
buildings
there's also no other access really from
anywhere else in an easy manner so it's
unlikely to be sold away because there
just isn't a simple access to it would
be very complicated
um to get it can I just look at the
drawings again of what's proposed
through you chairman the block plan the
elevations the floor plan the elevations
please
yes so for me that's um really modest I
mean I actually think on the balance of
probability it is going to be used for
family and I think it is gone man I mean
if it's been mowed since 2011 that's a
pretty significant time and it can't be
splits you can't sort of look at it and
think well we'll sell that away it can't
be um uh sold away and I mean it's very
close to all the new housing
developments in Malden it's got business
units all around it you're not going to
see it so for me the benefit outweighs
the harm
can I yeah thank you chairman with your
your forbearance I think we're getting
out we're getting ahead of ourselves a
little bit aren't we and we're getting
we're getting carried away and that it's
going to be a residential Annex and I
think the application is
proposal to create a home gym and office
that may be used for occasional
overnight accommodation for visiting
friends and family that's its
predominant use so that's clearly
um that use is linked to the main house
although it does go on to say that it
could be repurposed in the future to
provide a granny Annex if required and
at this stage it'll still be occupied by
family members so that's a secondary use
sometime in the future that may indeed
involve another planning application
um I don't know depends on the internal
layout so you know I I think you know it
is very clearly in the garden and I take
on board what Mr Johnson has said in
that you know when you're applying for
an Annex to a large country house and
it's in a field you know that's
completely away from the main house of
course that's absolutely correct but
this is literally
a matter of feet from the existing Farm
office buildings and you know very close
to the main house now you know I'd live
fairly close to my aged parent
surviving parent and you know if I could
get her near to me I would do that
nearer to me I would but I wouldn't
necessarily want her literally
a matter of feet provided that you've
got your elderly relative that you can
get there within
a minute or two if they press an
emergency Bell and that could be the
other side of the gut you know I think
we're getting down to you know the
distance that an Annex has to be from
the main house you need to get to it for
it to fulfill its purposes to have an
infirm family member in you need to be
able to get to them quickly but probably
not as close as you can hear them when
they're shouting at you when they've
so if you I think you know where know
where I'm coming from so I I totally
accept what the the officers have said
but I think this is clearly
in a garden whether it is legitimately
Garden or whatever but it is you know
on balance I think that this would tick
the boxes for
an office to accommodate a home gym
and offices and for with occasional
overnight accommodation at this stage in
time
and I just wanted to clarify the
description of the development
um
with all due respect I think what
council Diamond has
discussed in terms of what they want to
use a property for is their intended use
home office gym Etc and that and in the
future sort of thing yeah the actual
description is detached Oak framed
ancillary residential Annex
that will be it's its definition yeah uh
we will have no control over the
internal layout yeah once that uh
description has been applied that would
be it's lawful use
for which it can be used for a purpose
which
it hasn't been demonstrated
um that there is that functional need in
accordance with the SPD and to which we
will then have no further control thank
you chairman
well chairman right yeah
I accept that and I have to agree to
disagree
um and I think on balance the
the the
um the the impact on the local area the
damage to the local area is is
insignificant that we shouldn't worry
about it too much and I'm quite happy if
somebody's prepared to Second a proposal
that we uh we approve this application
well I have got well that I'm not I'm
not convinced that address is the
reasons for refusal
where are you Mr Johnson because that's
you are after all the professionals or
the one that matters if that was a
proposal does it address the
because that's the important thing
otherwise we haven't got something you
know
yeah thank you chairman I mean I mean I
think as I said earlier that for me you
know the fundamental thing is the
satisfying the policy criteria
um there are yeah we've discussed there
are a number of elements where you can
apply a factoring degree assessment too
but it has not satisfied the policy
element this is something which carries
even beyond the decision that we make
here and this is where we need to be
very mindful in terms of the decisions
I'm not sure if Hannah do you want to
say something or I wasn't sure
no okay yeah so so that that for me is
is the is the fundamental Point what
will be taken away from
um making a uh or supporting a
recommendation as proposed by Council of
Durham in terms of how we apply our uh
our policies the robustness of them the
president that may be set when other
applications come through these are
fundamental things that May challenge us
in the future thank you chairman I can
leave you to think about that chairman
I'm happy to to come back under 5.17
where the the SPD criteria in my view
that the majority of those are static we
can argue a case to satisfy the majority
of those so I think that we can overcome
that particular policy and that's why my
uh proposal stands right I believe
councilor Keys was the first to
second that are you still happy with
that I do have oh I won't go straight to
a vote because we do still have
councilor Morgan and councilor white to
speak again and and indeed Council
Stevens
thank you uh right I was really it was
just two points the first is that it
seems the officers have accepted uh that
um the this area up on which this um
thing is going to be cited was actually
started to be used uh as gar or as
ancillary to the land from 2005 onwards
and indeed from 2011's was being known
as part of that's part of the lawn which
to my mind means that in in point of
fact if they wanted to make an
application for a certificate lawful use
to development as as gardenland then
that would have to be that would be
personal that's that's the first point
but the second point is I I reiterate or
uh what council Dobbs said in with
regards to the points 5.1.7 uh where it
seems to me that all those uh have have
apart from the fact that they haven't
got an actual occupant designated and
I'm assuming that if they did have that
would presumably that that the all those
aspects as being a analytics
accommodation have been met thank you
thank you
that's it that we will need to delegate
the conditions and anything to do with
Rams and so on to officers so as long as
we're agreeing on that okay so I have
Council of white and Council students
yeah Among Us just a question for
clarification I um the officer raised
the question about the internal layout
could be changed but I understood and
maybe I'm wrong that they could do what
they like with the internal layout
pretty much I didn't think that we had
any control over internal layouts I knew
we'd done windows and doors and external
but I thought internally could pretty
much do what they wanted if building
regulations don't mind
Mr Johnson
yeah thank you chairman no I think I I
did make mention of that yeah
thank you
there was just one other it's just one
other small point just back on what one
uh Council Morgan was saying
um
the the issues around curtail is not
curtillas that's Garden land not Garden
land that's understandable but not
withstanding that even if it were Garden
land yeah uh that is no justification
Itself by residential Annex
criteria still have to be met
just wanted to sort of make that point I
mean I mean we have residential we have
residential Annex applications in fact
the appeal
um reference we made uh in in the in the
in the officers report was in a
residential Garden
I accept that point in time but the
point is that if one of the reasons for
refusal of this Annex was that it is
non-residential land so if I appreciate
the the residential that doesn't mean to
say you can automatically have an Annex
one of the reasons that this has been
opposed by officers is because they
believe it isn't residential land and if
as I've stated that this has been used
effectively as residential land
producers of 10 years before now then in
my view it is so that seems to me it's a
rather sort of you know frankly dismiss
that particular objection thank you okay
let's come to council students well
Council Stevens hadn't managed the word
yet
it's fine thank you chair um I will say
what I was going to say but then I will
just ask is it 10 years or is it 20
years on that point thank you
thank you man just to clarify that it's
normally 10 continuous years it's not
just a 10-year point in the past yeah
when an application regarding a change
of use
um over a tenure or even a four year
period is submitted they have to show
continuous use yeah
okay thank you chairman please carry on
and do we have evidence that there has
been 10 continuous years of use please
we have aerial photographs to show that
it was moan from 2011.
um
and at the point of the site visit there
was a
um washing line situated in that area of
land that is not to say that for 10
years it has been integrated as part of
the garden it's been moan
this prior to that it was part of the
adjacent farmyard
um so they haven't submitted
yes but through you chairman that
doesn't necessitate that it's
residential Garden land
we haven't demonstrated that it is
residential cartilage
I haven't seen any evidence to question
that because I recall another issue
um in my own village where somebody put
golpo football goal posts and I accept
the fact that they're different from
rugby
um on land that was Agricultural and
they were reinforced against them and
they had to remove them so by putting
rugby posts or anything on there I would
cut that I would say that that class is
there ask Garden paraphernalia and and I
would think you know if it's been
initially yes and if it has been that's
whole Mill Farm uh and so you know we
can't have our cake and eat it and you
know clearly if it was first moan in
2005 and incorporated into the 2011. if
you like closely moan
it certainly wouldn't have been returned
to agriculture in the meantime and then
Ramon again so I think that on the
balance of probability and and with an
application for a certificate of
lawfulness of course the applicant would
have to prove beyond all Reasonable
Doubt but it had fulfilled the 10
continuous years but I think
it would be the
probably more difficult to prove that it
hadn't been
um so uh you know yes you couldn't farm
that little tiny piece because I'm
yeah so it's awake as an account exactly
so yeah chairman you know that is that
is the situation
um you know and would we really want to
go through the hoop of making the
applicant of refusing this making the
applicant supply for a certificate of
lawfulness and then going through this
rig role again I I don't think that
would be seen as being entirely
reasonable so that is why chairman I
think we we you know I think we
discussed this in in fullness and and I
think
you know I support councilor Morgan you
know in my opinion apart from having a
named person
to qualify for the um specialist needs
housing it does tick all of those boxes
to a certain extent so that is those
other reasons
probably go to a vote but I don't
know Steven said actually
sorry counselor Stevens please carry on
and I do have Council Miss whites but if
you know if not at reiteration please if
possible Council Stevens thank you okay
well I'll try not to reiterate but I
probably do want to reiterate himself no
I know you didn't I know I know um I do
want to Echo some of the things that
have been said just to make people
really think about them
um okay so the proof of residential use
seems to be be a bit of a moot point I
don't know if anyone could prove it
either way
um I don't think it matters that you
can't see it I don't think that's really
the point the fact that there's a wall
there well it doesn't really matter lots
of Gardens have walls in them Hedges
whatever dividing them up as we've heard
councilor Keys referred to what the
applicant might build here instead but
that's not what we're considering here
and it wouldn't be residential as
councilor Thompson said
um but above all it isn't an Annex and
as we've heard it doesn't meet the
functional test it would be a building
that could evolve into a separate
dwelling house and that's what our
policies are meant to rule out and every
time we go against those we're opening
we're exposing ourselves to the risk
that all the other areas where there's a
bit of pocket of land here and there or
well let's make it into a garden and
when nobody notices then we can put
something on it and then in time well we
might have elderly parents living in
here or actually that track that comes
in from the north that's not up to much
now but it could be in the future the
fact that it could be accessed
independently from the main house really
does emphasize this for me it could
evolve into a separate dwelling house
and for that reason I don't think we
should approve it thank you thank you
councilor white new point my no yes it
was really I mean I I was just looking
at it thinking that for me an oak frame
building complies with policy d one on
design that was just something I was
thinking so and sympathetic materials
sits well in the landscape
Etc thank you yes let's let's have the
vote so we have a proposal in the name
of councilor Durham seconded by
councilor Keys um Miss Casey have we
have you got that you have you got the
wording of that
yes
okay
thank you right in that case um and as I
said earlier delegating the conditions
Etc to officers so those in favor of
that proposal to approve
those against
okay that proposal passes the
application is refused so moving on to
our last item and you'll be very pleased
it's approved sorry it's approved what
did I just say it's approved I'm sorry
I'm sorry it's been a long day it is
approved in line with councilor Durham's
proposal uh you'll be very pleased to
hear there are no items of urgent
business that the chairman has
considered and I close the meeting with
thanks to officers and members and
anybody out there who's listening at 8
14.